and there was a lot of empathy for
Israel and then with the jabalia refugee
camp being bombed deputy mayor of
Jerusalem her name is FL Hassan Nahum uh
I interviewed her in Jerusalem I was
blown away by this woman her energy her
passion her love for the city of
Jerusalem was just absolutely incredible
uh she was on Andrea Mitchell's show on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC and Andrea Mitchell who is a
Jew and a homas apologist here she is
blaming Israel for the rise of
anti-Semitism talk about the conflicting
imagery which is so painful for all
sides but you had this Savage Massacre
on October 7th and I've seen the video
and it is unspeakable yeah and there was
a lot of empathy for Israel and then
with the jabala refugee camp being
bombed and now the hospitals you know
Europe is on fire with anti-israel prot
protests and messaging the US now we see
this counter march today which is trying
to balance it out but there were
problems all all across the us as well
in anti-semitic incidents is there a
better way for Israel to process this
war something that the US has been
urging quietly and now publicly in terms
of using smart bombs not dumb bombs
smaller Munitions more ground than air
well Andrea you know this is a war we
didn't ask for we didn't provoke we
didn't start it was something we never
expected uh to have 2,500 terrorists
come in and you saw it yourself hours of
torture innocent babies who were
decapitated women whose pregnant women
whose stomachs are open babies taken out
you know how horrific that was I don't
know of any country that wouldn't want
to go and defend its citizens from
essentially an existential threat and
not just that the leaders of Hamas are
saying we're going to do October the 7th
again and again and again so Israel has
been put in an impossible situation now
Israel Has the strength to flatten Gaza
but we're not doing it we're putting our
soldiers our young men In Harm's Way
going door too because we're a moral
Army because we don't want to kill
innocent we have opened a safe passage
from Shiva from the first day and Hamas
was shooting people outside and not
providing the safe passage we're talking
about electricity and Fuel and
incubators underneath Shiva Hospital
there's a whole nerve center of a
terrorist base which is bigger than the
New York subway now what's fueling that
they've got according to our
intelligence months of fuel down there
months of food and months of water and
so essentially we're protecting their
citizens more than they're protecting
their own citizens that's what the world
should be outraged about we can always
have these image Olympics and one image
is worse than the next I'm not
justifying anything but we are in a war
there's a difference between War which
is ugly and war crimes which is
purposefully going for innocent citizens
Maya is it not as simple to say that if
Israel would just use Smart bombs
instead of dumb bombs that people would
be less against Israel I mean she's
she's just extraordinary this woman
she's just absolutely insane but
actually you were with me in Jerusalem
when I when I interviewed the deputy
mayor I think you introduced actually
she was incredible she's an unbelievable
unbelievably effective Communicator for
Israel I mean she just reiterated
something that you said earlier actually
I think I think there's an interesting
misconception that people think that the
smarter they are the more complex they
get and the truth is the is simple the
truth is simple it's not complicated and
Flur does it in the most unbelievable
way first of all you know what if you
could create a smart bomb so to speak I
think she should get off her show try
and invent with because she'll become a
millionaire if she can do that probably
a billionaire but it's just a ridiculous
it's just a ridiculous notion to make
and it just shows the extent and the the
the just unbelievable again ignorance
that comes to this around this entire
conflict what does even whatever but I
think that FL speaks for the Jewish
people for most of us and for definitely
for the Israelis this is not complicated
it is not a complicated situation
everyone's making it out to me but it's
not Kamas are responsible for both
Israel is responding morally to every
single situation it is put in to an
extent that we're sacrificing our own
people to ensure that there is no
innocent life left no innocent life is
taken for no reason our soldiers are
dying in Gaza instead of them just
blitzing it it's what I said before it's
not that I believe in the blitzing of
Gaza whatsoever but it's a possibility
and it wouldn't be a crazy response I
think if this in in the past paba
Hiroshima right this is It's there's a
reality to the fact that when somebody
comes in and says we want to kill as
many people as we possibly can the
response to that is to respond with
strength and not to respond with
weakness and the fact that we're being
requested that time and time again is a
joke and I think that going simple
uncomplicated reiterating the same
messages over and over again Kamas is
responsible we are trying to do the
right thing Kamas is responsible we are
trying to do the right thing there is no
other option come up with the better
solution you can't is the way to go
forward